Ucrania acusa a Rusia de terrorismo
energético con pocos avances en el campo
de batalla kiev señala que la estrategia
de Moscú es dejar sin electricidad a los
ciudadanos ucranianos a puertas del
invierno en las últimas semanas las
tropas rusas han enfocado a sus ataques
a instalaciones eléctricas ucranianas
por medio de misiles y aviones no
tripulados una movida que las
autoridades militares han divulgado
públicamente según el presidente
ucraniano más del 10% de la población
está temporalmente sin electricidad y
Espera que el racionamiento energético
sea drástico
alrededor de 4,5 millones de personas
han sido desconectadas temporalmente del
consumo de acuerdo con los calendarios
de emergencia y estabilización por lo
tanto quiero hacer un llamado en dos
cosas La primera es la atención de las
autoridades asegúrense de que no haya un
uso innecesario de electricidad en todas
las ciudades y comunidades de Ucrania la
otra es que definitivamente no es el
momento para vitrinas brillantes
letreros anuncios y otras
y otras nuevas regiones estarían
afectadas mientras la contraofensiva
ucraniana Avanza en la estratégica
gerson donde continúan las evacuaciones
unas 5000 personas estarían saliendo de
la región cada día según las autoridades
pero rusas locales evacuaciones que
fueron respaldadas este viernes por el
presidente ruso que es por su parte ha
denunciado deportaciones forzadas de
civiles hacia territorio ruso lo que
constituiría un crimen de guerra las
declaraciones cruzadas se dan en
momentos en los que las tropas rusas
podrían estar preparando su retiro de la
única gran ciudad ucraniana que lograron
conquistar desde el inicio del conflicto
en medio de una contraofensiva que no
baja el ritmo a pesar de los ataques
rusos que según el presidente ucraniano
no lograrán